Conrad wasn't or flowing techniques so
Conrad of current laws alone techniques
not a great translation of Condren
wasn't but Clement was our techniques
dead when one doesn't work out house
change into another technique a lot of
times when people are studying idea they
see the important techniques and
something from the cure laws the rights
of e keone Kela something we don't give
those techniques or something from the
noggin laws that you know kokyu nage
evening me Naga do to Naga she and I get
one of those kind of technique that's
what they think of as being important
techniques in Aikido but there's a lot
of other techniques we do that we really
don't talk about much right
so is scaping techniques that don't you
love that this is also an important
series of paintings so if I it's
grabbing to here probably get out of
this kind of microgravity one of the
very commonly prescribed methods is a
triangle symbol what we call trying to
set which is this position and when I do
that I strike Mike in the face and you
can see while I'm doing this technique
then I'm pulling my shoulder leg and
keeping mind away from me and that
enables me to pop free here nice final
session to pop creak another technique
that we see when we often don't talk
about is it so cold war is returning to
the outside and with this I'm going to
put my arm here on my clock and I'm
gonna turn my wrist in this makes it
yucky pokey over this rehearsal here and
I turned out and and pop free so we're
here
and another technique we often see an
idea is she will learn and that's a
technique done to the inside stuff
coming inside now it's important to
understand the techniques do not have a
100 percent success rate if any one
technique had a hundred percent success
rate when we just do that technique it
would be the greatest system in the
world they look at never defeat us and I
do it would be the best and I would say
it's great and we know that's not true
so you have understood techniques have
failure points if we flow these
techniques together we eliminate the
chance that we're going to have zero
success - what I mean by that is let's
say I go to my triangle step here it
might feel strong and tough I hit in the
face
pullback husband in I have no success
durations what can I blow into
security cleared his arm by using soapy
water now I can pour myself a warrant by
rollies discounts movies his arm kind of
stronger so I think it's the outsider
user but that may be big shoot proof we
get each morning so as I find one
technique doesn't work let's say try the
step I can work another technique so the
more it now that Network and is my
programming that can go Gucci war that
didn't quite clear then I can use trying
to set the techniques fit inside each
other really really nicely so if you
practice flow through like this you
start to think the idea probably need to
be moving so instead of just performing
a technique if you just do the forms
then this always food or it's always
just a setup or EPO right something like
that that's not the case of course there
are a lot more escape techniques and I
should right now I can probably think of
six more off the top of my head really
really quickly and you should look in
the boards and see what those are and
then practice them loop them together so
you get a flow and drill find the way to
work these this is a nice live we're
microfiber I try to escape and I know
until I find my escape so not only
trying to do those techniques I'm trying
to escape the techniques will naturally
start to link together and I will find a
way to achieve my goal
in that situation
you